großer empfang für königin margrethe von
dänemark in flensburg es geht um 100
jahre deutsch dänische grenze
saarbrücken empfang für außenminister
heiko maas frankreichs botschafterin und
viele gäste
sie feiern 100 jahre saarland die dänen
machen als erster in europa die grenze
dicht wegen corona grenze zu auch
zwischen deutschland und frankreich
corona stresstest für europa
ausgerechnet am hundertsten geburtstag
der deutschen grenzgebiet
[Musik]
welche zeit war das tor jetzt saarland
da war schon selbständig wäre das hier
noch französisch 100 jahre saarland
erklärt mit autokennzeichen ja noch
kommen die deutschen schilder ja aber
ich kann das doch dass das aber noch ab
1918 19 als die ersten autos bei uns
hatte man diese nummernschilder horst
schneider hat michaela jede menge sah
historie gesagt sein freund und er sein
hobby historiker
das sind diverse ausweispapiere die ein
saarländer früher so braucht durch die
wechselvolle geschichte hat auch werner
weiter vier verschiedene pässe gerne
weiter ist 95
er erinnert sich gut an diese kindheit
an einer grenze die sich ständig
verschob
[Musik]
heute spaziert er mit seinem freund
regelmäßig dort entlang wo er als
kleiner junge auf seine mutter war
französin seine oma lebte in frankreich
und straßburg nach luxemburg in 100
jahren geschichte war das saarland immer
wieder spielball zwischen deutschland
und frankreich
und gerade vor und während des zweiten
weltkrieges war sie plötzlich doch da
die grenze ein riesiger
stacheldrahtverhau hier entlang des
waldes zehn meter breit
die bergleute haben sich hier bei nacht
und nebel mit der schere eine passage
durchgeschnitten und wir kinder liefen
natürlich auch durch und da hat uns die
deutschen zöllner erwischt ja und dann
gab es einen strengen verweis unsere
eltern haben uns strikt verboten noch
mal nach mehr in bord zu gehen
sein freund horst schneider ist 20 jahre
jünger
auch er ist hier groß geworden hat grenz
erfahrungen gemacht andere als die
seines freundes polizisten
was dabei genau da so war das so kenne
ich meine jugendzeit und ich muss sagen
ich bin jetzt bist mein freund etwas
jünger wie er und er kannte die
geschichte die krieg seit der
nachkriegszeit kann ja besser das weiß
ich jetzt nicht
aber ich schaue hier wir beide sind
charlie naja hier kommt man auch der
wand und das ist unsere heimat
ihre heimat ist das hier die flensburger
förde ziemlich genau in der mitte
verläuft die landesgrenze zwischen
dänemark und deutschland eine grenze die
nie etwas trennendes hatte sagen skipper
micha und kai von 1 der vorsitzende des
einzigen dänischen segelvereins in
deutschland im märz konnten sie wegen
kohona wochenlang nicht segeln
es war schon fast beklemmend bei aller
schönstem frühlingswetter auf die förde
zu blicken die war leer
vor einem jahr feierten sie die dänische
königin margrethe in flensburg beginn
der feierlichkeiten zum hundertsten
jahrestag der grenzziehung dieses besuch
ist für mich der bedeutend wenn wir
nächstes jahr die festlegung die heutige
grenze erinnern und feiern können
vor 100 jahren stimmte die bevölkerung
im ehemaligen herzogtum schleswig ab
welcher teil dänisch und welche deutsch
werden sollte die große feier fiel aus
kuh- oder änderte alles
stattdessen war die einzige offene
grenze dicht grenzkontrollen nichts ging
mehr autofahrer mussten zurück für
anwohner auf beiden seiten bedeutete das
noch mehr einschränkungen denn seit
einiger zeit gibt es auch einen zaun von
dänemark gebaut damit wildschweine aus
deutschland nicht rüber kommen können
schutz vor der schweinepest
das hat schon etwas trennendes sagt die
63 jährige anke baumann die direkt an
der grenze wohnt
ich finde das landschaftlich schön ich
bin sowieso auch für offene grenzen wir
mal so sagen aber anderen seite kann ich
auch die den verstehen weil also ich bin
schon so halbwegs zähle ich finde die
nicht minder halt und dänemark ist nur
ein kleines land die kapazitäten sind da
ja ganz anders als hier jetzt in
schleswig holstein oder deutschland und
da kann ich schon verstehen dass die ihr
land schützen wollen wofür auch immer
also alles dicht auch im saarland
an über 50 übergängen war die grenze zu
stresstest für die region
dabei hatten sie erst anfang januar ein
großes fest bis 100 jahre saarland party
in saarbrücken ehrengast die
französische botschafterin
es gibt eine sonderausstellung auf
deutsch und französisch sie zeigt das
hin und her bis nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg war das saarland ein
unabhängiger kleinstadt es gab eine
eigene währung einer nationalelf und
saarländische spitzensportler die
internationale titel nach hause brachten
dann volksentscheid das saarland wieder
deutsch sein und wird 1957 zum ersten
neuen bundesland kleine
wiedervereinigung
der deutsche außenminister heiko maas
hat den termin genutzt
nach einem gipfel in brüssel vor reisen
nach berlin moskau und jordanien mal
kurz nach hause denn auch seine
persönliche geschichte ist typisch sei
nämlich meine oma hat ihr leben lang im
gleichen ort in der gleichen straße und
im gleichen haus gewohnt
in den letzten 100 jahren hätte sie
aufgrund der völkerrechtlichen zuordnung
des saarlandes fünf verschiedene pässe
haben können im märz 2020 wird der pass
plötzlich wieder gebraucht
großrosseln saarland petrocelli
lothringen der kleine grenzverkehr ist
nicht mehr normal
[Musik]
horst schmadl der hobbyhistoriker war
schockiert sogar in seiner kindheit als
es schengen noch gar nicht gab waren die
grenzkontrollen weniger streng erkennen
sein wer nie nie wahrgenommen wird also
bei uns war immer kleineres in
großrosseln das war immer 1 die brücke
war immer symbol für siege und
niederlagen in den zeiten als
deutschland und frankreich feinde waren
aus marl hat hunderte fotos davon in
seinem keller corona hat alte
ressentiments aufgeweckt europa hat
geschlafen
jeder hat sein eigenes süppchen kocht
warum habe ich an europa warum habe ich
brüssel warum mal straßburg warum velich
abgeordnete im europaparlament und die
schlafen am 15 juni um 0 uhr ist es
soweit die grenze im norden ist nach
zwei monaten wieder offen
an den übergängen wie hier bei flensburg
stauen sich seit stunden die autos der
touristen aus deutschland und viele
wollen in die ferienhäuser an dänemarks
küsten und dabei natürlich auch die
ersten sein
das deutsch-dänische grenzgebiet heimat
für die dänische minderheit in schleswig
holstein und etwa 15.000 deutsche in
süddänemark der grünen-bundesvorsitzende
robert habeck hat daniel günther den
cdu-ministerpräsidenten hier eingeladen
in ein naturschutzgebiet ich hier bin
ich zu hause und sie ist mir voll diese
diese region voll ans herz gewachsen
und dazu gehört eben auch diese
zweisprachigkeit oder die doppelte
kultur die damit verbunden dass sich
eine region die lange umkämpfte
blutigsten kriege die hier geführt
worden leute sind gestorben und die
grenze nach norden nach süden zu
verschieben
er hatte verständnis in kona zeiten das
verkehrsströme auch eingeschränkt werden
müssen das ist wichtig war dass man sich
nicht zu sehr unter einander austauschen
eben das virus möglichst auch
aufzuhalten aber jeden war ja auch klar
das ist jetzt eine hoffentlich kurze
episode jeder freut sich darauf dass die
grenzen wieder geöffnet werden
und es war ja die ganze zeit einfach
auch immer druckvoll
bevölkerung beiderseits der grenzen auch
auf die regierung endlich zu öffnen
man habe sicher und lange zu diesem
ausflug verabredet sagt robert habeck
er betont dass 2020 durch corona
deutlich wird dass eine offene grenze
nicht so selbstverständlich ist wie man
es hier jahrzehntelang gewöhnt waren
zur begrüßung eine brezel das reiche
saarland wird überschwemmt von armen
wirtschaftsflüchtlingen aus bayern
topthema bei der großen zeiten jeden tag
kommen 500 bis 800 an der grenze
natürlich ist die redaktionskonferenz
inszeniert genau wie die idee dass das
saarland superreich und unabhängig ist
aber warum eigentlich nicht dachten
diese beiden saarländischen firmen
hätten wir damals beim sei statt eines
abgestimmt werden wir jetzt vielleicht
wie luxemburg wir werden ein geständiger
start und wir fanden es interessant dass
es nicht immer nur so durch zu sprechen
sondern mit hilfe von der mockumentary
also einer doku fiktion das ganze zu
zeigen
ab mitte der siebziger jahre wird dieser
metropole als finanzplatz zu den
hauptdarsteller war sah größen
juli zu ende denken kaká hat eine
führungsposition heiko maas ist
außenminister an der saar oskar
lafontaine ein oppositioneller und peter
altmaier ist wirtschaftsminister des
großen nachbarn deutschland
das ist das geheimnis der europäischen
integration und da ist es von schwenker
oder leona fest nicht so weit zum
informellen eu ministerrat in litauen
lettland oder irland zurück zur realität
den späten anschluss an deutschland hat
das saarland wirtschaftlich nie wirklich
aufgeholt die kohle ist lag der stahl in
der krise aber ihre besondere geschichte
im grenzland hat die saarländer
zusammengeschweißt wenn die leute sagen
dass er das so klein dann brodelt es
ergänze ländern sagen ja eigentlich
waren wir doch wir hätten können und es
ist aber nicht so das muss man auch
sagen
im film demonstrieren sie für europa für
offene grenzen
die bilder haben sie vor über einem jahr
inszeniert sie sind jetzt wieder
brandaktuell
in flensburg ist es gefühlt wieder ein
bisschen so wie früher sagt susanne
gelhard die in einer kleinen seitengasse
der fußgängerzone schmuck selbst
herstellt und verkauft dänische kunden
waren lange nicht da die verluste für
geschäftsleute groß jetzt geht es wieder
aufwärts
die dänen sind noch ein bisschen
verhalten wir wundern uns auch ein
bisschen ich glaube sie sind erst mal
wirklich anwesend um in den restaurants
zu verweilen
die kaufkraft ist noch nicht so ganz bei
uns angekommen aber es fühlt sich wir
merken die stadt wird merklich voller ja
es ist wieder leben die grenzschließung
ein riesenproblem auch am einzigen
deutschen gymnasium in süddänemark in
apenrade
auch hier fiel wegen corona der
unterricht viele wochen aus das gewohnte
miteinander von deutschen und dänischen
schülerinnen und schülern fand nicht
mehr statt
das virus und die folgen sind immer noch
thema corona wird nicht verdrängt wird
nochmal so klar das ist eigentlich sehr
unterschiedliche länder sind vorher war
dass man sie ja dänemark und deutschland
man wusste es sind zwei unterschiedliche
länder aber jetzt ist man glücklich
getrennt irgendwie schon jetzt wissen
wir durch die ganze getreten vorher war
sie offen da konnte nach deutschland
jeder konnte nach dänemark aber jetzt
sind sie jetzt kommt nicht darüber im
segelverein überall bei der dänischen
minderheit in schleswig holstein ist das
bedauern groß deswegen corona die
feierlichkeiten zum hundertsten
jahrestag der grenzziehung ausfallen
muss also ein solcher staatsbesuch mit
königliche yacht hätte nicht stattfinden
können 2020 wir sind heilfroh dass wir
das gehabt haben und ich kann mal so
sagen innerhalb der dänischen minderheit
ist die freude selbst ein halbes jahr
oder länger ja schon immer noch groß
über diesen besuch das ist bei uns
täglich immer noch im gespräch weißt du
noch und wie die königin hier war und
nun war mein segelverein der dänische
der finanzpakt wir waren federführend
und haben eine ein- und auslaufparade
organisiert für die dänische königin es
war sehr sehr großes ereignis auch für
mich persönlich vor allem hat mich das
sehr sehr berührt
im jahr 2020 wollte man an den grenzen
groß feiern
stattdessen hat ein virus genau hier
gezeigt wie zerbrechlich europa ist